hello and welcome to this video playing
Renee 64 all if you ranae yeah I have to
get on the scoreboard here two games two
losses that doesn't sound good let's see
if i can change something about that
have an English ship with tons of
possible transposition so okay he goes
for foreign film type of thing let's see
if it takes all goes back now this is a
line that I like a lot for white
actually so we'll see how he handles
this think I start with this Bishop g7
22 thats night you for so I think after
church g7 this is an early 94 probably
just Knight f3 com ok ok so there's
potentially h4 or 22 first so it's
playing age 5 just like that ok I like
to stop that
okay so it's a fairly typical position
here of the out of this this line where
it's always a tough call between black
being close to equal or wide having a
slide pool I think probably why does a
bit better here in this pin this case b4
b5 yeah okay let's go before so night
might come to d file if i move my knight
94-95 this kind of thing ok I've got 95
getting some claim on them on his vporn
interesting so he wants to probably just
take but I don't mind that of course
this just gives me more time 45 and twin
side play Roxy one looks like the normal
move and now a4 b5 is the looks looks
good question is what is this actually
doing if I can get this to work yeah
it's a little bit it's a little bit more
comfortable for while I wonder if Bishop
h6 something here or if i should rather
keep this on the board difficult i'm the
bishop might just must map lop might
just point into thin air
mm yes 25 unfortunately otherwise group
takes age 5 or something what is some
some kind of idea so here take sticks
right an 85 at the end so calm you just
get but I didn't think about this move
it all and that's pretty bad should've
flawed and it should have thought about
it at least
you
that's probably equal hook a 7d for ya I
can take that there's that much
happening here can you bring the king
dru c7 and then try move the points not
really does it look all that threatening
c5 I have to check so what is the object
set really venetia five I go on maybe
he's coming around now yeah he's a bit
quicker down that's true okay so I need
to get some player on my own so would be
five probably just take here come to
this
not much threatening here maybe look at
five as a threat now well threat is a
strong word okay so let's go to e5
coming here can check a couple of times
and then push the HP com so very dry
calm hi money yeah if he gets to hawaii
Five I mean clock Trillium I'm just us
then clock mom are wrong yeah I have to
I have to that's nothing that I can do
so let's see it was a little bit little
bit disappointing oh I think this
opening line is really quite nice for
white I didn't get so much out of it so
this feels kind of normal I can switch
on and it is sometimes so so forget it
yeah why does a bit more comfortable
with this additional Center porn but
it's really nothing nothing special hook
here he trades that and I probably need
a little bit more precision here but I
think ahead a little something to be
perfectly honest I b5 is interesting but
I think this was also not bad maybe 95
is just to a bit too simplistic Bishop
g5 is interesting at you prevent
counseling yeah this is this a bit bit
nicer for white but
add to us I 24 somehow did not did not
have cleaned a default on the radar so
you can try it a little bit because of
the minority attack b5 is something that
is slightly annoying for black what is
the engine evil I kind of yeah a little
something look here and maybe b5
Caucasus this is just not not anything
at all whoopee one is maybe a bit more
interesting yeah I think this is just
extremely Jewish I me a demo actually
there was some interesting moments
though with g5 maybe I should take okay
so this is a bad decision I can actually
go into the king and porn ending now and
win or what computer it's not quite not
quite sure i would i would be kind of
surprised if that wins 15 takes 16 b 6
king before and an f5 and the engine
claims the drawer but this is probably
like a one temple thing chartis losers
yeah this loser said it's pretty simple
so i have to take king d5 king c3
kimmy14 c4 i think i actually would have
found that because there's really not
much else and we we have a drawer the
drawer okay no takes a four losses shoot
yeah
oh no not good here not good I have to
play king be three and then d5 [ __ ] yeah
you know pretty clear that this doesn't
work mmm bad okay yeah I have escaped
with the draw I that was lucky that was
lucky wasn't really aware of that I mean
I was aware of the trick okay for its
not the different versions we that was
close ok guys thanks for watching